all right the evidence of corruption and
bias inside Special Counsel of Muller's
team it just keeps piling up now it does
get complicated I promise we'll go step
by step we'll break it all down for you
tonight but breaking right now Sarah
Carter investigative reporter is now
telling us that the top investigator the
guy we've been telling you about
Andrew Weissman he met with journalists
from the AP last April to discuss the
news outlets investigation into Paul
Manafort now the next day the AP
published a major expose about Paul
Manafort and alleged money laundering
and sources are telling Sarah Carter
that the AP reporters in that meeting
they were actually promising to share
documents and other information about
mana for with the Department of Justice
there's going to be a lot of news in
recent in coming weeks about the media
and the role they're playing in all of
this now tonight the AP is denying it
saying it's that categorically untrue
now at the time of this conversation
Weissman was the head of the Justice
Department's fraud division and would
then go on a short time later to join
Muller's team the following month and
according to the report Weissman
notified his superiors about to sit down
with the AP and during that time he
wasn't working for the metaphor case and
he didn't have access to any documents
related to it now this shows that
Weissman had prejudice going into the
investigation against Paul Manafort now
that's on top of his troubling history
remember Weissman he led the highly
controversial obstruction of justice
case remember Meghan's our the Arthur
Andersen accounting in the Enron scandal
remember he destroyed that company tens
of thousands of people lost their job
that verdict was later overturned in a
Supreme Court unanimously
now Weissman also put four merrill
executives in jail for a year those
convictions were also overturned in that
case by the fifth US Circuit Court of
Appeals this is why we have to question
the decision of making robert muller why
would he make these appointments of
people like Weissman and only democratic
donors why given this history was he
ever appointed and why would Muller fill
that team with people that gave money to
Hillary Clinton the DNC
over $50,000 to candidates like this and
Barack Obama also a big follow-up
tonight to our exclusive reporting last
night on the Clinton bought and paid for
phony fake news Russian propaganda
dossier with all that salacious material
that we have confirmed has been used was
used by the Obama administration to
literally surveil members of the Trump
campaign team and of course then
President or president elect Donald
Trump and members of his team now we
have been all over the story from the
beginning and just to give you an idea
of just how serious this is a source is
telling me this is going to all be
proven right to quote him Hannity you're
way over the target at low altitude and
everyone else in the destroyed Trump
media will be proven so wrong on so many
levels he said you can't even imagine
how bad this is gonna get now in
addition to the phony dossier being used
to spy on members of the Trump campaign
Sarah Carter is also reporting and we
have confirmed this that information
about systemic FISA abuse will also be
exposed soon maybe as early as next week
now surveilling the Trump campaign isn't
the only incident it goes way beyond
that this is the real Russia scandal the
media's never reported on and it has
nothing to do with what the fake news
media has been spoon-feeding
the entire country for the past year
about Trump Russia collusion it doesn't
exist there's no evidence even top
Democrats have been telling us but
nobody listens and they still keep
reporting it anyway unimaginable take a
look well that you know the allegation
of course is that the Russians in the
hacking and dumping of documents in the
election had essentially relationships
with Trump campaign people but I'm not
prepared to say that there's proof you
could take to a jury do you agree with
this conclusion that the president has
reached there was no evidence of
collusion you know we haven't seen any
of that whatsoever George we've been
looking and showing everything that they
possibly have that has not led to that
the last time we spoke senator I asked
you if you had actually seen evidence
of collusion between the Trump campaign
and the Russians and you said to me and
I'm quoting you now you said not at this
time has anything changed since we spoke
last well not you no it hasn't I know we
need to go simple just to be clear we
have me there has been no actual
evidence yet no it has not been no not
yet
now instead the real collusion involves
Hillary Clinton in the DNC spending
millions of dollars trying to influence
an election by funding all of the
salacious Russian source dossier that
the Obama administration then used to
spy on an opposition party in a
presidential election year president
Trump himself reacting to all of this by
tweeting disproven and paid for by
Democrat Stasi a used to spy on Trump
campaign did FBI use Intel tool to
influence the election at Fox and
Friends did Dems or Clinton also pay
Russians where are hidden and smash DNC
servers he's asking questions where are
crooked Hillary's emails
what a mess by the way it's only getting
bigger now the president raises some
very constitutional questions here
there's so much about this dossier that
we still don't know about but here's
what we do know and we're going to break
this down in dissect this entire scandal
so that everybody understands that even
fake news CNN they may understand how
serious this really is let's go back to
October 2015 the Washington free beacon
they paid fusion gps to do standard
political opera search on them candidate
Donald Trump it had nothing to do with
Russian sources
Christopher Steele was not involved at
all the mi6 agent then in April of last
year when it was clear that Trump would
be the Republican nominee back in 2016
Hillary Clinton and the DNC that Donna
Brazile said that Hillary Clinton
controlled especially the money took
over the funding of the project all told
they would pay fusion gps over ten
million dollars through a law firm by
the way the DNC Hillary's campaign they
used the same law firm and the former
British spy Christopher Steele then at
that point when the Democrats are paying
him Hillary's paying him he gets
involved in June of that year now keep
in mind
to Vanity Fair Steel has paid Russian
sources over the years as part of his
quote job and during that summer Steele
quickly goes to work using current
former Russian government sources to
produce what we now know is the phony
fake news dossier that included the
salacious and completely false
information including Donald Trump in
Russia at the ritz-carlton Moscow with
hookers urinating on beds Wow now keep
in mind former FBI director James Comey
he even testified under oath that the
contents of the dossier were unverified
well that apparently did not stop steal
from reportedly briefing news outlets
let's see like the New York Times The
Washington Post Yahoo News The New
Yorker and fake news CNN all about the
dossier
now that means Steele was trying to
influence an election with a dossier
that Clinton paid for of course Clinton
wanted this then fast forward November
28th according to a reporter David
Cramer an ally of Senator John McCain he
meets would steal steal agrees to give
him a copy of the dossier to give McCain
which Kramer does then in early 2016
McCain then gives the dossier to the FBI
director James Comey see how it's now
tying together and in January of last
year BuzzFeed well they decided to
publish this fake news document that
president Trump's personal attorney
Michael Cohen just this week is now
suing over for defamation now here's
where it gets shocking according to
reports during the summer of 2016
former Trump campaign associate member
Carter page he spied on
they used the FISA warrant and we found
out from other reporting the former
Trump campaign chairman Paul Manafort he
was surveilled before and after the
election and now thanks to Sarah Carter
and John Solomon and others we have
confirmed tonight this new information
through three separate sources we
started it last night the Clinton funded
unverified dossier with all that
salacious material and Russia propaganda
that was used as a justification to
obtain FISA warrants to spy on members
of the Trump campaign
and then the president-elect and we're
learning more about the dossier from the
very guy who helped created because
Senator Dianne Feinstein released his
congressional testimony now Feinstein's
excuse for doing it is pretty lame
pretty unbelievable
she told NBC News today that the reason
that she released the the information
and the exchange with Congress is
because well she had a bad cold and the
dog ate my homework and that slowed down
her mental abilities Wow really
so what Feinstein did is a major breach
of trust with Senate investigators but
actually it provided some very revealing
information let's give you some all
right Glenn Simpson a fusion GPS all
right during that testimony that he said
he never even bothered to verify what
not even bother to verify what Steele
brought him from his Russian sources and
that he was against Donald Trump during
the election shocking and we also know
that Simpson met remember he met with
the Russia lawyer both before and after
the meeting at Trump Tower remember the
one with Don jr. and mana Ford and Jared
Kushner in June of 2016 oh we're really
supposed to believe that Glenn Simpson
who hates Trump who never verified the
dossier that it's a mere coincidence
that he's meeting with the Russian as he
testified to and Simpson also met with
former top DOJ official member Bruce or
now tying that together and ORS wife
Nellie actually worked for fusion GPS I
know this is a lot of information
let me explain exactly what this all
means Clinton bought and paid for this
phony dossier this lie this propaganda
she was hoping the Russian propaganda
and lies would influence the general
election the Obama administration then
politicized and as I've been warning
about weaponize these powerful tools
that we give our intelligence community
and they use them to go after an
opposition party in a presidential
election year so we have Clinton putting
the fixon remember Bernie Sanders we
learned Donna Brazile fix was in in the
primary it was done done deal
Bernie
you had no shot the fix was also in
think about this with the Clintons with
the exoneration before the investigation
in her email server scandal remember was
call me and Peter struck they were
writing a letter of exoneration they
didn't even investigate yet and then she
here was trying to use the dossier to
fix the general election so what is
being exposed are massive abuses of our
constitutional and civil liberties our
Fourth Amendment rights and protections
against unreasonable search and seizure
and this is now reaching a point that
you can't even imagine top officials at
the highest levels of your government
they're all involved they will be
exposed now